This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. There is a reasonable assumption we make as we go through life. Groups act in their own self-interest. Merchant sell things in order to make money. Employers want to hire the best employees. Sports teams want to win matches. The assumption of self-interest is also the lens through which we understand how individuals behave. We can see why someone might lie on a resume in order to get
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。我们对生活有着一种合理的假设。群体为了自身利益行事。商人卖东西是为了赚钱。雇主想要雇佣最好的员工。运动队想要赢得比赛。对自身利益的假设，也是我们理解个人行为的视角。我们可以理解为什么有人会在简历上撒谎，以便
ahead. We also know that no one would lie on their resume to make themselves look worse. When people are accused of wrongdoing, it makes perfect sense that the guilty would claim to be innocent. But every ounce of common sense tells us, no innocent person would ever confess to doing something wrong. We understand as a matter of common sense and intuition that people behave in ways that favor their self-interest. How in God's name does that favor your self-interest? How and why people come to betray their self-interest? This week on Hidden Brain. In the sixth grade, Saul Casson received an assignment from his teacher to write a book report. It took him about a nanosecond to decide to write about his hero, Mickey Mantle.
脱颖而出。我们也知道，没有人会在简历上撒谎来让自己显得更糟糕。当人们被指控犯错时，有罪者声称自己是无辜的，这完全合情合理。但我们常识中的每一分理智都告诉我们，没有哪个无辜的人会承认自己做了错事。常识和直觉让我们明白，人们的行为往往符合他们的自身利益。老天爷啊，这怎么能符合你的自身利益呢？人们怎么会、为什么会做出背叛自身利益的事？本周的《隐藏的大脑》。在六年级时，索尔·卡森收到老师布置的一项作业，要写一篇读书报告。他几乎没花半秒钟就决定写他的偶像——米奇·曼特尔。
I was a huge Yankees fan and I wanted to do a really good job. The baseball star was not the only object of Saul's affections. His sixth grade teacher was up on a pedestal too. I loved Mrs. Avery. I had a crush, to be honest, on Mrs. Avery. I wanted to impress Mrs. Avery. And so I spent a lot of time on this book report. I just remember being excited to get the grade back.
我是洋基队的超级粉丝，我想把这项作业做得非常出色。这位棒球明星并不是索尔倾注热情的唯一对象。他的六年级老师也同样备受崇敬。我爱阿弗雷迪太太。说实话，我对阿弗雷迪太太有点迷恋。我想给阿弗雷迪太太留下深刻的印象。所以我花了很多时间在这篇读书报告上。我只记得当时满怀期待地等待成绩发下来。
I thought it was a really good paper. I'd spent a lot of time on it. And when she called me up, she would call people and they'd come up and get their paper. This was toward the end of the school day. And I just remember her glaring at me in such a way that I looked at the grade. And there was, with a circle around it, a big red F. And there was, with a circle around it, a big red F. I said, I don't understand, and she says, will you plagiarize it? Saul found himself dumbfounded. He loved Mrs. Avery, and he loved Mickey Mantle,
我觉得这是一篇非常棒的论文。我在上面花了很多时间。当她叫到我的名字时，她会叫其他人上去拿他们的论文。那是快要放学的时候。我只记得她怒气冲冲地瞪着我，以至于我看到了那个分数。上面有一个圈起来的大大的红色F。上面有一个圈起来的大大的红色F。我说，我不太明白，她说，你是抄袭的吧？索尔感到惊呆了。他爱阿弗雷迪太太，他也爱米奇·曼特尔，
and he had poured his heart and soul into the book report. I didn't want to break out into tears in front of my classmates and in front of her, so I held it together. I got home, flicked open into tears in front of my classmates and in front of her, so I held it together. I got home, flicked open the door, there was my mother, and I burst out crying. Mrs. Avery accused me of cheating. She didn't ask me if I plagiarized, she told me that I did. And I just will never forget the helplessness that I felt at having been accused of something I didn't do and not really knowing how to respond in a way to defend myself.
而且他把自己的心血都倾注在了这篇读书报告上。我不想在同学们和她面前哭出来，所以我强忍着。我回到家，猛地推开大门，我的母亲就在那里，我顿时放声大哭。阿弗雷迪太太指责我作弊。她没有问我是不是抄袭，她直接断定我抄了。我永远也忘不了那种无助感——被指控做了一件我根本没做过的事，却又不知道该如何为自己辩解。
It was Saul's mother who finally obtained justice. She demanded proof from Mrs. Avery that the book report was plagiarized. Mrs. Avery looked for evidence but couldn't find any, so she changed Saul's grade. But the moment of helplessness stayed with Saul, why had he been unable to speak up? Saul grew up to become a psychologist. His area of study, how people interpret the actions of others. He was especially fascinated by juries. Here were people whose conclusions about defendants had life and death stakes.
最终为索尔讨回公道的是他的母亲。她要求阿弗雷迪太太拿出这篇读书报告是抄袭的证据。阿弗雷迪太太找了证据却没找到，于是她修改了索尔的成绩。但那种无助的时刻一直留在索尔心中：为什么他当时无法开口为自己辩解？索尔长大后成为了一名心理学家。他的研究领域是：人们如何解读他人的行为。他尤其对陪审团着迷。这些人对被告作出的结论关乎生死存亡。
To evaluate the psychological factors that shaped how juries think, Saul came up with cases where some jurors might feel a defendant was guilty, while others might feel he was innocent. Saul figured ambiguous cases would shed light on how people make up their minds about guilt and innocence. He started running experiments with volunteers playing the role of jurors. He noticed there were some cases where his volunteers were totally unanimous. A couple of cases came back that elicited no variability. As far as everybody was concerned, everybody was guilty. Fortunately, we also asked subjects in those studies to explain
为了评估塑造陪审团思考方式的心理因素，索尔设计了一些案件，在这些案件中，一些陪审员可能会觉得被告有罪，而另一些人可能会觉得他无辜。索尔认为，模棱两可的案件将有助于阐明人们是如何对有罪和无罪做出决定的。他开始用扮演陪审员的志愿者进行实验。他注意到，在某些案件中，他的志愿者们完全异口同声。有几个案件的结果毫无分歧。在所有人看来，每个人都有罪。幸运的是，我们还要求这些研究中的受试者解释
a verdict. What was the basis for your verdict? And in the cases that I recall, everybody cited a confession. A confession. When a defendant in a criminal case admitted he had done something wrong, volunteers playing the role of jurors saw these as open and shut cases. Someone says they're guilty? They're obviously guilty. My first response was, well that's interesting, it looks like we'll have to remove confessions from evidence in order to use cases.
他们的裁决。你作出裁决的依据是什么？据我回忆，在这些案件中，每个人都提到了供词。供词。当刑事案件中的被告承认自己做了错事时，扮演陪审员的志愿者们就会认为这些是板上钉钉的案件。有人说自己有罪？那他显然就有罪。我的第一反应是，嗯，这很有趣，看来我们得从证据中剔除供词，才能使用这些案件。
Saul wanted cases where volunteers disagreed with each other. Cases involving confessions, where everyone agreed with everyone else, were useless. It became a nuisance variable, so right away we tossed out cases involving confessions because confessions were a nuisance. It happens so often in science as well as in life. We fail to notice something important because we are so intent on something else. It took Saul a while to realize his nuisance was telling him something important. As he continued to study juries, Saul decided he needed to better understand how police procured
索尔想要的是志愿者们意见不一的案件。那些涉及供词且所有人意见一致的案件毫无用处。它成了一个干扰变量，所以我们立刻扔掉了涉及供词的案件，因为供词是个干扰因素。这种情况在科学界和生活中经常发生。我们因为专注于其他事情而忽视了重要的事情。索尔花了一段时间才意识到，他的干扰因素正在告诉他一些重要的事情。随着对陪审团研究的深入，索尔决定，他需要更好地了解警方在刑事审判中是如何获取
evidence in criminal trials. He decided to audit a law school class on evidence. I got the case book, I did all the reading, and there was a footnote in that case book in which they referenced an interrogation manual, the most popular interrogation manual. So I thought, wow, how interesting to see what they're doing to interrogate. And so I went to the library and pulled out that edition of that manual, and I read the book. What kind of techniques were in this manual, Saul?
证据的。他决定旁听一门法学院的证据法课程。我拿到了案例汇编，完成了所有的阅读，而在该书的一个脚注中，他们提到了一个审讯手册，那是当时最受欢迎的审讯手册。所以我想，哇，去看看他们在审讯时是怎么做的，一定很有趣。于是我去了图书馆，翻出了那本手册的版本，并读了这本书。这本手册里都有哪些技术，索尔？
Just one or two examples. Well, for starters, the opening salvo of an interrogation was to bring in a suspect and declare an accusation of guilt. This, of course, is exactly what Mrs. Avery had done in the sixth grade. We know you did this. Don't lie. In fact, I believe in that first manual, they advised the interrogate to come in with a folder full of materials and toss it on the table and said, we've got a lot of evidence against you. And they suggested doing that, even if you didn't have a whole lot of evidence. So right out of the gate, I'm looking and I'm saying, okay, wow, these are powerful tactics. These are almost milgram-esque.
只举一两个例子吧。好吧，首先，审讯的开场白就是把嫌疑人带进来，直接宣称他有罪。这当然正是阿弗雷迪太太在六年级时做过的事。我们知道是你干的。别撒谎。事实上，我记得在那本最初的手册里，他们建议审讯人员带着一个装满材料的文件夹走进来，把它扔在桌上，并说：“我们掌握了大量对你不利的证据。”他们建议即使没有那么多证据也要这样做。所以一上来，我就在观察并心想，哇，这些真是强有力的战术。这些简直带点米尔格伦式的色彩。
In the early 1960s, Stanley Milgram conducted a series of experiments on blind obedience. He tested a volunteers with comply with instructions from an authority figure. The most famous experiment featured an experimenter who demanded that a volunteer subject someone else to painful electric shocks. 150 volts. In reality, no one received shocks. The experiment was designed to test if volunteers were willing to go along with crazy instructions. If the volunteer resisted, the experimenter had a series of verbal prads to keep the experiment going. It's absolutely essential that you continue.
20世纪60年代初，斯坦利·米尔格伦进行了一系列关于盲目服从的实验。他测试了志愿者对权威人物指令的配合程度。最著名的实验涉及一名实验员，他要求志愿者让其他人承受痛苦的电击。150伏。实际上，没有人真正受到电击。该实验旨在测试志愿者是否愿意顺从疯狂的指令。如果志愿者进行抵抗，实验员会有一系列言语催促来让实验继续下去。你继续下去绝对是至关重要的。
You had no other choice teacher. You must continue the experiment requires that you continue. And the prods are designed to get a subject to first administer a 15 volt shock and then a 30 volt shock. And in 15 volt increments to bring that subject up to the point where they would be asked to administer a 450 volt shock which on Milgram shock machine was listed as XXX severe shock Answer is woman
你别无选择，老师。你必须继续，实验要求你继续。这些催促旨在让受试者首先施加15伏的电击，然后是30伏。并以15伏的增量，让该受试者达到被要求施加450伏电击的程度，这在米尔格伦的电击机上被列为“XXX严重电击”。答案是女人
born of 50 volts When you look at this paradigm you go nobody's gonna do that Well we're going out of the reviews as a door. The experiment requires it to go on teaching. 65% of subjects go all the way up the shock scale to 450 volts. That's a meal-grim. Now I look at the interrogation manual. You bring them in, isolated, no friends or family members or lawyers present. There is instead of an
诞生的50伏。当你看到这种范例时，你会觉得根本没有人会那样做。好吧，我们走出门外，实验要求继续进行教学。65%的受试者一直把电击强度拉到最高档450伏。这就是米尔格伦效应。现在我再看审讯手册。你把他们带进来，进行隔离，没有朋友、家人或律师在场。现场没有作为权威人物的实验员，而是一个拥有真实权力的警探，那个警探的目标就是指控你某事并让你承认有罪。通过逐渐升级的过程和列出的一系列催促，警探的目标是让你做一个小的供认，或者承认“我在那里”。然后是稍微多一点的承认。我看到了发生的事。然后是稍微多一点的承认。
experimenter as an authority figure, a police detective who has real authority, and that police detective aims to accuse you of something and get you to make an admission of guilt. And through a process of gradual escalation and a series of prides that are listed, the detective's goal, is to get you to make a small confession or an admission of, I was there. And then a slightly greater admission. I saw what happened. And then a slightly greater admission.
我只是参与了一小部分。最终，一次15伏地推进，目标是让这个人做出完全的有罪供认，并配合一份解释时间线和故事的完整叙事供词。米尔格伦服从实验中的权威人物，只是一名穿着白色实验服的心理学实验员，他对这些受试者没有真正的权威，也没有真正的权力。如果像心理学实验这样的权威人物能够产生那种水平的服从，你能想象一个对你的命运和未来拥有权力的警探能产生什么吗？
I was minimally involved. And eventually, 15 volts at a time, the goal is to get that person to make a full admission of guilt, coupled by a full narrative confession that explains the chronology and the story. The authority figure in Milgram's obedience experiment, it's a psychology experiment or wearing a white lab coat who has no real authority and no real power over those subjects. If an authority figure like a psych experiment can produce that level of obedience, can you imagine what a detective who has power over your fate and future might be able to produce?
这就是让我感到不安的地方。我一直在想，天哪，如果他们把无辜的人带进这种境地，他们就会得到类似米尔格伦实验的结果。索尔意识到他正面临两个强有力的事实。事实一：陪审团相信提供供词的人。事实二：警方被教导要使用一系列强有力的心理技术从人们口中逼取供词。要让这个问题存在，你并不需要假设侦探怀有恶意。和我们其他人一样，侦探们也认为没有哪个无辜的人会承认自己有罪。
And that's what unnerved me. I kept thinking, geez, if they bring innocent people into the situation, they're going to get some milkroom-like results. Saul realized he was confronting two powerful facts. Fact number one, Jury's belief people when they offer confessions. Fact number two, police are taught to extract confessions from people using a series of powerful psychological techniques. You don't have to assume bad intent on the part of detectives for this to be a problem. Like the rest of us, detectives assume no one who is innocent will admit to being guilty.
索尔决定更仔细地研究供词科学。但他发现根本没有什么供词科学。但他发现，根本没有什么供词科学。当有人说他们做了错事时，他们确实做了错事显得如此不言而喻、显而易见，以至于根本没有人真正去研究过它。不过，索尔确实找到了一个早期案例，那是20世纪初由一位名叫雨果·芒斯特伯格的心理学家描述的案例研究。芒斯特伯格有一个章节名为《不实的供词》，他在其中描述了芝加哥的一起案件——贝茜·霍利斯特谋杀案。有趣的是，我认为这让他对
Saul decided to look more closely at the science of confessions. Only he found there was no science of confessions. Only he found, there was no science of confessions. When someone says they did something wrong, it seems so self-evidently obvious that they did do something wrong that no one had really studied it. Saul did find one early example though, a case study described in the early 20th century by a psychologist named Hugo Munsterberg. Munsterberg has a chapter titled Untrue Confessions and in it he describes this case out of Chicago, the murder of Bessie Hollister. What was interesting and what I think made him skeptical about the
供词产生怀疑的原因在于，首先，招供的嫌疑人认知能力有限，作为嫌疑人来说是一个脆弱的人。他随后意识到，警方接着对其实施了长达数小时的审讯，在此期间，据描述他一次又一次地添油加醋地编造故事。事实证明，他在那个故事中提供了一些细节，而其中一些细节被证明是虚假的。所以我们遇到了这样一种情况：他被长时间审讯，他是一个脆弱的嫌疑人，他提供的供词与案件事实相比并不是特别准确。然而检察官却极力推进，说实话，我没骗你，在一周内他就被定罪了，不久之后他就被绞死了。索尔开始在历史书寻找其他虚假供词的案例。
confession was, first of all, the suspect whom confessed had limited cognitive abilities and was a vulnerable person to issue as a suspect He then realized that they then brought him in for hours of interrogation in which he was described that he embellished a story from one telling to another Turns out he provided some details in that story and it turns out that some of those details were false. And so we have a situation where he was interrogated for long periods of time. He was a vulnerable suspect in the confession he gave was not particularly accurate in relation to the case facts. And yet the prosecutor pushed forward and within a kid you not one week he was convicted and shortly thereafter he was hung. Saul started looking for other cases of untrue confessions in the history books.
他找到了不少。最终，他想出了一套分类系统。第一种是自愿虚假供词，比如1932年著名飞行员的儿子被绑架的那次事件。查尔斯·林德伯格当时是美国的英雄，他幼小的儿子被绑架了，正如你所能想象的那样，这是个大新闻，有200人自愿承认是他们绑架了孩子，但最终警方没有起诉他们中的任何人。最终，他们谁也没有参与其中。有趣的是，某种程度上带有讽刺意味的是，
He found quite a few. Eventually, he came up with a classification system. The first kind were voluntary false confessions, like the time in 1932 when a famous aviator son was kidnapped. Charles Lindbergh was at the time an American hero and his infant son was kidnapped and it was big news as you can imagine and 200 people volunteered confessions to that kidnapping and ultimately police did not charge any of them. Ultimately, none of them had anything to do with it. It's interesting, some extent ironic,
当有人自愿招供时，警方天然会产生怀疑，他们会寻找有罪的证据来佐证这种自愿的供词。所以他们可能会要求提供事实，例如：好吧，你说你犯了这个罪，跟我讲讲案件事实。向我描述一下犯罪现场，或者带我找到凶器，或者带我找到受害者。而无辜的自愿虚假供词者往往做不到这一点。自愿虚假供词是指无辜的人在没有任何
that when someone volunteers a confession, police are inherently suspicious, and they look for proof of guilt to corroborate that voluntary confession. So they might ask, for example, for facts. Okay, you say you committed this crime, tell me about the case facts. Describe the crime scene to me or lead me to the weapon or lead me to the victim. And invariably, innocent voluntary false confessors can't do it. voluntary false confessions are cases in which innocent people without any
来自警方外部压力的情况下，主动站出来承认他们并未犯下的罪行。有时候他们是在保护别人。可能是孩子在替父母掩盖，也可能是父母在替孩子掩盖，所以有时候这是一种理性的原因，而有时候，这也是一种充斥着病态、需要博取关注的原因。动机可能有所不同，但在我看来，自愿虚假供词并没有给刑事司法系统带来太多问题。那么第二种虚假供词，就是你所说的顺从型供词。
external pressure from police step forward and confess to crimes they didn't commit. Sometimes they're protecting somebody else. It might be a child covering for a parent or a parent covering for a child, so sometimes it's a sort of a rational reason like that, and in sometimes it's a sort of a rational reason like that. And sometimes it's a reason that reeks of pathology and somebody needing to gain attention. The motives may vary, but it is my sense that voluntary false confessions don't present much of a problem for the criminal justice system. So a second kind of false confession is something that you've termed compliant confessions.
当你开始查阅历史记录时，你会发现相当多的这类例子，有些甚至可以追溯到几十年前甚至几个世纪前。例如，你讲述了发生在17世纪萨勒姆的事件。是的，萨勒姆审巫案就是一个很好的例子。顺从型虚假供词，是指某人在承受巨大压力的情况下的案件。他们有动机去结束这种压力。他们想要摆脱那种糟糕的处境。他们甚至没有去考虑长期的后果。他们可能开始相信，招供比否认参与更符合他们的最大利益。
And as you started to look at the historical record, you find quite a few examples of this, sometimes going back decades or even centuries. You tell the story about events that took place in the 17th century, for example, in Salem. Yeah, the Salem, which trials are a great example. Compliant false confessions, these are cases where somebody is under great amounts of stress. They are motivated to put an end to that stress. They want out of that bad situation. They're not even thinking about long-term consequences. They may have come to believe it's in their better interest to confess than to deny involvement.
他们知道自己是无辜的，但为了摆脱糟糕的境地，他们还是招供了。这类案件贯穿了整个历史。在萨勒姆审巫案中，一些未能招供的嫌疑人被处决了。在做虚假供词和被处死之间做出选择时，许多人选择对自己的罪行撒谎。当然，萨勒姆审巫案发生在300多年前。同样的事情今天不可能发生，对吧？真的不可能吗？你知道的，当时我在威廉姆斯学院教书。
They know they're innocent, but they confess anyway as a way to get out of a bad situation. Those types of cases go back throughout history. In the Salem Witch Trials, some suspects who failed to confess were executed. Given the choice between making a false confession and being put to death, many chose to lie about their guilt. Of course, the Salem Witch Trials took place over 300 years ago. The same thing couldn't happen today, could it? Could it? You know, I was teaching at Williams College.
那是马萨诸塞州的一所文理学院。那是2002年。我正在为秋季的课程做准备。有个制片人打电话说：“我想知道你能不能帮我们看一些供词。”我说：“好的，是什么案件？”她说：“我们答应过不把这事告诉任何人。”我说：“没问题，这是保密的。”她说：“是中央公园慢跑者案。”我陷入了沉默。
It's a liberal arts college in Massachusetts. It was 2002. And I was preparing for classes in the fall. And this producer called and said, I wonder if you can look at some confessions for us. I said, OK, what's the case?" And she said, we promised not to mention this to anyone. I said, sure, it's confidential. And she said, it's the Central Park jogger. And I went silent.
广告回来后，我们将讲述中央公园慢跑者的故事。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。在我们开始下一个环节之前，先简单说几句：我们将讨论心理学家索尔·卡森研究过的两起暴力犯罪。这些案件包括关于谋杀和强奸的血腥描述。1989年4月的一个傍晚9点左右，一名28岁的女子在纽约中央公园跑步时遭到袭击。她遭到殴打、强奸，并被留置等死。
When we come back, the story of the Central Park Jaga. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. A quick word before we start this next segment, we're going to be discussing two violent crimes that psychologists Saul Cassin has studied. These cases include graphic accounts of murder and rape. Around 9pm on evening in April 1989, a 28-year-old woman was attacked while taking a run in Central Park in New York. She was beaten, raped, and left for dead.
凌晨1点30分左右，她被两名路人发现时已经不省人事。她被紧急送往医院，并在昏迷状态下度过了12天。心理学家索尔·卡森还记得关于这起骇人听闻的罪行的种种新闻报道。对于一个本就神经紧绷的城市来说，这就是压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草。报纸上全都是“我们必须破案”的头条。我完全理解，当这件事发生、当它被报道且罪行如此滔天时，整个城市都处于愤怒状态，并强烈要求我们找到凶手。在72小时内，纽约市警察局破了案。当时有许多孩子在那个晚上跑过
Around 1.30am, she was found unconscious by two passers-by. She was rushed to the hospital where she remained in a coma for 12 days. Psychologists saw Cassand remember the news stories about the horrific crime. For a city that was already on edge, this was the breaking point. The papers were just filled with headlines that we got to solve this. I understand fully that when this happened and when it was reported and the heinousness of the crime, the city was in the state of outrage and demanding that we find who did this. Within 72 hours NYPD solved the case. There were a number of kids running through
公园，对一些路人胡作非为，警方立即开始搜捕人员，进入他们的社区，把其他人带进来，他们审讯了各种各样的孩子，最终找到了五个供认的孩子——年龄分别为14、15、16岁。全部都是黑人或拉丁裔。警方对他们进行了数小时的审问，
the park that night, wreaking havoc on some bystanders, and police immediately started rounding people up, going into their neighborhoods, bringing others in, they interrogated all sorts of kids, and ultimately found five kids who confessed 14, 15, 16 years old. All were black or Latino. Police questioned them for hours
并拿到了他们的供词，其中有四份录像供词。纽约市警方在20世纪70年代、80年代处理供词的方式是，侦探在摄像机拍不到的地方进行审讯。他们把嫌疑人审讯到准备招供的程度，然后将他们移交给助理地区检察官，由后者带着摄像机介入并录下供词。请问你的全名叫什么？
and got their confessions, including four on videotape. The way New York City worked their confessions in those days, starting in the 1970s, 1980s, was the detectives interrogated off camera. They brought their suspect to a point where they were ready to confess and then they delivered them to an assistant district attorney who stepped in with a camera on and took the confession. Would you please tell us what your full name is?
你的全名是？你的全名是？你的全名是？好的。好的。请报一下你的全名好吗？你的全名？哈里，德米特拉，
Your full name is? Your full name is? Your full name is? Okay. Okay. And would you please state your full name? Your full name? Harry, Demetra,
说谎。好的。请坐起来告诉我你叫什么名字？凯伦，蒂姆伯，说谎。谢谢。请坐起来告诉我你叫什么名字？我是参议员的名字。对不起，你必须离那个远点。参议员的名字。你还得等我多久？
put your lies. Okay. Would you please sit up and tell me what your name is? Karen, Timber, put her lies. Thank you. Would you sit up and tell me what your name is? I'm in the name of Senator. I'm sorry, you have to keep it from that. Name of Senator. And how long do you have to wait for me?
他们描述了慢跑者跑步时的样子。他们描述了她的位置。他们描述了把她拖进草丛的过程。那里有清晰的脚印。他们描述了一个头部被重物击打、衣服被扒掉并被遗弃等死的女人。你们就把她扔在灌木丛里。
They described the jogger as she was running. They described her location. They described dragging her down through the grass. They were clear tread marks. And they gave a description of a woman who had been beaten in the head with a heart object, closed, pulled off, and left for dead. You just left her laying in the bushes.
是的。你们有没有试着把她藏起来让她不被发现？我试着在他们做的那天把她藏起来。你无法忽视视频中的那些陈述。他们说对了一些事实。他们基本上讲的是同一个故事。他们之间存在一些令人烦恼的出入和矛盾，但他们说对了足够的事实。
Yes. Did you try to hide her so she would get banned? I tried to hide her on the date they did. You cannot look past those statements on video. They got some of the facts right. They're basically telling the same story. There are some annoying disparities and contradictions between them, but they get enough facts right. some annoying disparities and contradictions between them,
一些令人烦恼的出入和矛盾，但他们说对了足够的事实。这些男孩都没有律师在场。在16岁柯里·怀斯的录像供词中，他坐在一个看起来像教室的地方。时间已经过了午夜。他的膝盖因紧张的能量而颤抖。检察官用问题对他进行严厉盘问。请问你的姓氏是什么？
but they get enough facts right. None of the boys had attorneys present. In the video confession of 16-year-old Corey Weiss, he's sitting in what looks like a classroom. It's past midnight. His knees are shaking with nervous energy. A prosecutor grills him with questions. What's your last name, please?
为什么？为什么？你今年多大？16岁。你上学吗？是的。你在哪里上学？错误步高中的。
Why? Why? And how old are you? 16. Did you go to school? That's right. What do you go to school? The wrong steps in high school.
你在那里上几年级？他说他参与了强奸。他在现场并扮演了一个微不足道的角色。我相信他说过，当别人脱下她的裤子时，他抓住了她的腿。他当时在做什么，以及他做了多少？你们是为了她的崩溃才去的吗？没有。
And what grade are you in there? He said he was involved in the rape. He was present and he played a minimal role. I believe he said he had held her legs while someone else pulled her pants down. What was he doing as much as he was doing? Were you guys after her crash? No.
我差点说没有。我能看到他脸上的表情。我感觉有点糟糕。那种，这是我第一次做极端的行为。而且还是对一个女性。当你听到这样的话时，他不仅描述了发生了什么，还描述了他自己表现出的懊悔。
I was about to say no. I could see the expressional face there. And I felt kind of bad. That kind of, this is my first extreme I did to. And it's a female history. When you hear a statement like that, he not only describes what happened, but then describes his own expression of remorse.
他基本上说，我很抱歉我做了这件事。这是我的第一次强奸，也将是我的最后一次。这是我的第一次强奸。我以前从没做过这个，这将是我的最后一次。这是一份不仅传达了有罪供认和与犯罪事实相关的准确叙事细节的供词，而且他现在还在反思自己的动机、悔恨和责任承担。法官和陪审团怎么能忽视这样的陈述？当你拥有四份这样的陈述时，尽管它们彼此并不完全吻合，
I'm sorry I did this, he basically said. This is my first rape, it's gonna be my last. This my first rape. This I never did this before, it's gonna be my last. Here's a confession that's not just communicating an admission of guilt and some narrative details that are accurate in relation to the crime facts, but now he's reflecting on his own motivation and remorse and acceptance of responsibility. How does a judge and a jury look past that statement? And when you have four of them, even though they don't align with each other perfectly,
陪审团怎么能忽视这四份陈述呢？所有这五个青少年都被定罪了。好几年里，几乎所有人都认为他们是有罪的。然而，这些定罪并没有解开谜团。接着有一天，他接到了美国广播公司新闻部的电话。制片人说，ABC收到一条线索，称这些青少年的供词是捏造的。于是他们给我寄来了两个大型施乐样式的盒子，我在接下来的几个星期里，在威廉姆斯学院的教学可能一塌糊涂，因为我完全被这个案件分心了。
how can a jury look past those four statements? All five teenagers were convicted. For several years most everyone thought they were guilty. The convictions continued to not solve however. And then day, he got a call from ABC News. The producer said ABC had received a tip that the teenager's confessions were made up. And so they sent me two big Xerox-type boxes and I spent the next couple of weeks probably doing terrible teaching at Williams because I was completely distracted by this case.
当我看完时，我惊呆了。没有任何证据表明他们有罪。这些供词相互矛盾。如果你还记得的话，其中有哪些细节实际上是互相冲突的？这就是复杂的地方，因为当然，有时候你在任何事件的现场都有三个目击证人，比如交通事故。事实上他们不会意见一致，事实上大量的心理学研究表明，他们不会在所有细节上都达成一致。
And when I was done, I was horrified. There was no evidence of their guilt. The confessions were contradictory. What was some of the details, if you remember it, that actually were at odds with one another. And this is the complicated thing because sometimes, of course, you have three eyewitnesses at a scene of anything that happens at traffic crash They in fact are not going to agree in fact There's a wealth of psychological studies that show that they will not agree on all of the details And in fact they might come up with important discrepancies and in some ways it's suspicious if five people at the scene of a traffic crash describe it perfectly Yes, so there's a part of you that thinks some of these
事实上，他们可能会提出重要的差异，从某种意义上说，如果交通事故现场的五个人把事情描述得完美无缺，那反而是可疑的。是的，所以你心里会觉得，其中一些差异可能实际上是因为人们忘记了，记忆是不可靠的，所以某些事情互相冲突其实并不令人意外。是的，我想这正是当时所有人都这么想的原因。我1989年不知道这一点，但我2002年得知，侦探向柯里·怀斯展示了受害者的照片。所以他能够描述她的特征。他被带到了犯罪现场。他对犯罪现场进行了生动的描述。他们所有人都是。
discrepancies might actually be because people forget memory is fallible, so it's actually not surprising that some things might clash with one another. Yes, and I think that's what everyone was thinking. I didn't know this in 1989, but I learned in 2002 that detective showed Cory Wise pictures of the victim. So he was able to describe her. He was taken to the crime scene. He gave a vivid description of the crime scene. They all did.
事实证明，其中两人被带到了犯罪现场。现在这污染了他们的记忆。现在，这不是他们的陈述。你激励了他们并给予他们奖励，因为他们认为合作最符合他们的最佳利益；
Turns out two of them were taken to the crime scene. Now that's contaminating their memories. That's now, this is not their statement. You've motivated and incentivized them because they think it's in their best interest to cooperate. you've motivated and incentivized them because they think it's in their best interest to cooperate and you've spooned that them information to provide a compelling accurate confession. But you're right. Nobody expected a full alignment of all the facts. And that's why I think the judges and juries they were convicted at two different trials were able to look past those discrepancies. The judges and jurors in the trials behaved exactly like the volunteers in Saul's early
你激励并促使他们去合作，因为他们认为这符合他们的最佳利益，而且你把信息“喂”给他们，让他们提供一份引人注目、准确无误的供词。但你说得对。没有人期望所有事实完全吻合。这就是为什么我认为法官和陪审团——他们在两场不同的审判中被定罪——能够忽视这些差异。这些审判中的法官和陪审团的表现，与索尔早期陪审团实验中的志愿者完全一样。
jury experiments. The suspects had confessed, case closed. It didn't matter that there was compelling evidence pointing in another direction. There were several semen samples taken, sent to the FBI lab. That summer, the results came back. First, all of those samples taken trace back to one person. They all match each other. That person was not one of those five confessors. The judge knew it, the jury's knew it. We have two juries in which they are told that they confessed on the one hand
嫌疑人已经招供，案件告破。有强有力的证据指向另一个方向也无济于事。警方提取了几个精液样本，并送往联邦调查局实验室。那年夏天，结果出来了。首先，所有这些样本都追溯到同一个人。它们彼此相符。那个人并不是那五个招供者之一。法官知道这一点，陪审团也知道这一点。我们有两个陪审团，一方面他们被告知这些人招供了，
but they're excluded by the DNA on the other. And as one of the jurors said in an interview years later, they had a confession and if there's a confession, what else is the need to know? ABC News contacted Saul because a previously convicted criminal had come far white to claim responsibility for the crime. A serial rapist named Matthias Reyes said he was the one who had attacked the Central Park Jogger. The sample taken from the crime scene matched his DNA. In December of 2002, their convictions were overturned. The DA's office filed a motion to overturn the convictions and the judge agreed with that motion and so they were convictions overturned. The DA's office filed a motion to overturn the convictions and the judge
但另一方面他们的DNA却被排除了。正如其中一位陪审员多年后在采访中所说的那样，他们有一份供词，既然有了供词，还有什么需要了解的呢？美国广播公司新闻部联系了索尔，因为此前已被定罪的一名罪犯挺身而出，宣称对该罪行负责。一名名叫马蒂亚斯·雷耶斯的连环强奸犯说，他才是袭击中央公园慢跑者的人。从犯罪现场提取的样本与他的DNA相符。2002年12月，他们的定罪被推翻了。地方检察官办公室提交了推翻定罪的动议，法官同意了该动议，因此他们的定罪被推翻了。地方检察官办公室提交了推翻定罪的动议，法官
agreed with that motion and so they were convictions overturned. The city eventually paid the boys $41 million for the mistake and for the suffering that they had inflicted on them. But what exactly happened during those confessions all? Do we know what happened that prompted the kids to basically make the confessions they did? Well, we know what the kids say happened. The kids were in the interrogation rooms for a range of 14 to 30 hours. The kids say they were threatened
同意了该动议，因此他们的定罪被推翻了。这座城市最终向这些男孩支付了4100万美元，作为对这个错误以及对他们造成的痛苦的赔偿。但索尔，在这些供词期间到底发生了什么？我们知道发生了什么促使孩子们基本上做出那些供词吗？好吧，我们知道孩子们说是怎么回事。孩子们在审讯室里待了14到30个小时不等。孩子们说他们受到了威胁，
that promises were made. They believed that by minimizing their involvement, each one I mentioned, nobody confessed to the rape, each one said I played a subsidiary minor role. Each one upon confession was arrested, and each one was surprised. They thought they were going home. It means they were led to believe that we think the role you played is no big deal. So cooperate with us and everything will be okay. And hence, they were surprised that they were put under arrest. I don't know what happened.
承诺被许下。他们相信通过尽量减轻自己的参与程度，我提到的每一个人——没有人承认强奸，每一个人都说我扮演了一个次要的、微不足道的角色。每个人在招供后都被逮捕了，每个人都很惊讶。他们以为自己能回家。这意味着他们被引导去相信，我们认为你扮演的角色没什么大不了的。所以跟我们合作，一切都会好起来的。因此，当他们被捕时，他们感到很惊讶。我不知道发生了什么。
I know that they claimed they felt physically threatened. They claimed threats and promises were made. Detectives deny it. I have no idea what happened behind the scenes, but I do know that their confessions were false and that each one minimized their role in a way that would make some sense. That's not unique to the jogger case. You see it all over the place. So we've looked in some ways at the strange phenomenon where some people will step forward voluntarily to say that they have committed a crime when they haven't and perhaps they're
我知道他们声称自己受到了身体上的威胁。他们声称受到了威胁，并且得到了承诺。侦探们对此予以否认。我不知道幕后发生了什么，但我确实知道他们的供词是虚假的，而且每个人都以一种合乎情理的方式尽量减轻了自己的角色。这在慢跑者案中并非独一无二。你到处都能看到这种情况。因此，我们从某种程度上探讨了一种奇怪的现象：一些人在没有犯罪时会自愿站出来说自己犯了罪，也许他们是在
looking for attention, perhaps they are psychologically disturbed. And we've looked at cases where people might come forward and confess, perhaps because they feel under pressure or they feel that this is a way that they can go home and see their families. You also talk in some ways about a more complicated psychological dimension of false confession, where these confessions are actually internalized. Talk about this idea, then in some ways, this might be the most difficult idea to absorb, where someone actually comes to believe that they have committed a crime. Yes, it was difficult to me. I didn't know what I was seeing the first time I saw it.
寻求关注，也许他们心理失常。我们还探讨了人们可能会站出来招供的案件，也许是因为他们感到压力，或者他们觉得这是回家看望家人的一种方式。你还从某种程度上谈到了虚假供词一个更复杂的心理维度，即这些供词实际上被内化了。谈谈这个想法吧，从某种程度上说，这可能是最难以理解的想法，即某人最终居然相信自己犯下了罪行。是的，这对我也很难。我第一次看到它时，我不知道自己看到了什么。
There was a case in the 1970s, in which a 17-year-old boy named Peter Riley, in New Canaan, Connecticut, came home and found his mother in a pool of blood having been beaten to death and stabbed. And Riley's confession was fascinating because first of all, he adamantly denied having anything to do with this. He had no history, no background,
20世纪70年代发生过这样一个案子：在康涅狄格州新迦南，一个名叫彼得·赖利的17岁男孩回到家，发现母亲倒在血泊中，被人殴打致死并身中数刀。赖利的供词非常引人入胜，首先，他坚决否认自己与此事有任何关系。他没有任何前科，没有背景，
no conflict with his mother. He wasn't a violent person. But he confessed. And why did he confess? Because after hours and hours and hours of interrogation, the detective offered him a polygraph exam, a lie detector test. Peter, you say you didn't do this. We think otherwise. We have evidence. Are you willing to take a lie detector test? Trusting in the lie detector test. Then trusting in his own innocence, Peter said, yes, I would. At which point, they administered a test and lied about the results. They said, Peter, you failed the test. And he said, that's not possible. And they said, well, it is possible. You fail the test. It shows deception. And sometimes the test tells us things about
与母亲没有任何冲突。他不是一个暴力的人。但他招供了。他为什么招供？因为经过长达数小时又数小时的审讯后，侦探向他提供了一次测谎仪检查，即谎言检测测试。“彼得，你说这不是你干的。我们认为并非如此。我们有证据。你愿意接受测谎仪测试吗？”出于对测谎仪的信任。又出于对自身清白的信任，彼得说：“是的，我愿意。”紧接着，他们对他进行了测试，并在结果上撒了谎。“彼得，你测谎没通过。”他说：“这不可能。”他们说：“嗯，这是可能的。你没通过测试。这显示出欺骗性。有时候，测试会告诉我们一些关于
you or a person that even they don't know about themselves. So it looks like you killed your mother, even if you don't remember it. Now, Peter's in this quandary. On the one hand, they're claiming to have unimpeachable medical. Sometimes the polygraph is referred to as medical evidence, sometimes it's referred to as scientific evidence, but it's objective, and it can tell us things about you and your behavior that even you don't recall. So Peter on the one hand has this unimpeachable evidence presented to him. Now he's 17.
你或一个人的事情，甚至连他们自己都不知道。所以看起来你杀了你的母亲，即使你自己不记得了。”现在，彼得陷入了两难的境地。一方面，他们声称拥有无可辩驳的医学证据。有时候测谎仪被称为医学证据，有时候被称为科学证据，但它是客观的，它能告诉我们关于你和你的行为的事情，甚至连你自己都想不起来。所以彼得一方面收到了这些无可辩驳的证据。而他当时17岁。
And God knows what his mental and emotional state is at this time. His mother is his only surviving relative. And he grows up trusting police and like most Americans doesn't know that they're allowed to lie about evidence. So Peter is trying to reconcile on the one hand, they say that I failed the lie detector test. And on the other hand, I don't remember it that way. And they presented him with some options. You know, sometimes that happens. People block unpleasant memories or people lose consciousness and they gave him a way to bridge this gap between their unimpeachable evidence and his lack of memory. And so they convinced him that he must have done it.
上帝知道他当时的精神和情感状态如何。他的母亲是他唯一的亲人。他在信任警察的环境中长大，像大多数美国人一样，他不知道警察被允许在证据上撒谎。所以彼得试图调和这种情况：一方面，他们说我测谎没通过；另一方面，我记忆中根本不是这样的。他们向他提供了一些选项。“你知道，有时会发生这种事。人们会封锁不愉快的记忆，或者人们会失去意识，”他们给了他一座桥梁，来弥补他们那无可辩驳的证据与他缺乏记忆之间的鸿沟。于是他们说服了他，让他相信这件事一定是他干的。
that he must have done it. He transitions from the state of denial to, well, it looks like I did it. When you hear these cases, often the first utterances are things like, I must have done it. It looks like I did it. It appears that I did it. They're not saying, oh, yeah, now I remember. They're concluding. They're inferring that they must have done it because after all you have this evidence. And then he transitions from that tentative hypothetical language of inference into a full blown, oh my god, I killed my mother, I pulled out a knife and I stabbed her. And that was his confession. He was immediately arrested and he was convicted. And a year and a half or so later, a new DA came into the office, looked through the case files, realized that Riley was elsewhere at the time of death that couldn't have been him,
这件事一定是他干的。他的状态从否认过渡到了“嗯，看来这确实是我干的”。当你听到这些案件时，通常第一句话都是诸如“我一定做过这件事”、“看起来是我干的”、“情况表明是我干的”。他们不会说：“哦，对了，我现在想起来了。”他们在推断。他们在推论说这件事一定是他干的，因为毕竟你们有这些证据。然后，他从这种试探性的、假设性的推论语言，过渡到了全面爆发的“天哪，我杀了我的母亲，我拔出刀刺死了她”。这就是他的供词。他立刻被捕并被定罪。大约一年半后，新上任的地方检察官翻阅了案卷，意识到赖利在案发时身处别处，绝对不可能是他，
and vacated his conviction and he was never retried again. That's the first time I'd seen, and I didn't know how to define it at the time, what turned out to be what we called internalization. I couldn't tell how momentary it was, how long it lasted, but it was clear that at some point, for some period of time, he came to believe in his own guilt. So the police basically have arrested someone. They've prosecuted the person, they found the person guilty.
于是撤销了他的定罪，他也再也没有被重新起诉。那是第一次，我当时不知道该如何定义它，后来证明这就是我们所说的“内化”。我无法判断这种状态是一闪而过还是持续了多久，但很显然，在某个时刻、在一段时间里，他开始相信自己是有罪的。所以警方基本上逮捕了某人。他们起诉了这个人，并判定这个人有罪。
A new DA comes in and basically says, the person's not guilty. Now, there's still someone who's been murdered, someone who's been killed. Yes. What do the cops do? In this case, they did nothing. They did not pursue these alternative suspects. There was good reason to believe that they had other suspects not saying they were the perpetrators, but certainly people worthy of investigation. And that did not happen. I've gotten to know Peter and a number of other exonerees who are frustrated that police didn't go back and reinvestigate the case and find out who killed their mother, their father or both. I mean, some people might look at your work and say, you know, Saul
一个新的地方检察官上任，基本上说：“这个人是无辜的。”现在，仍然有人被谋杀，有人被杀害。是的。警察会怎么做？在这个案子里，他们什么也没做。他们没有去追查这些替代嫌疑人。有充分的理由相信他们还有其他嫌疑人——并不是说他们就是凶手，但绝对是值得调查的人。然而这并没有发生。我已经和彼得以及其他几位沉冤得雪的人熟识了，他们对警方没有回去重新调查此案、找出究竟是谁杀害了他们的母亲、父亲或双亲感到沮丧。我的意思是，有些人可能会看你的工作然后说：“你知道，索尔·卡森花了大量时间试图把身处监狱的人救出监狱，但看待你所做的事情还有另一种方式，那就是：我们把错误的人送进监狱，这固然对那个错误的人、对彼得来说是一场悲剧，但对社会来说也是一场悲剧，因为真正的凶手没有被绳之以法。”不仅真正的凶手没有被绳之以法，而且统计数据还显示了这一点。在无罪计划的案件中，DNA排除了被错误定罪的人，有时DNA会指向某个真凶。在许多此类案件中，那个真凶后来又去犯下了
Kassen spends a lot of time trying to get people who are in prison out of prison, but there's another way to look at what you're doing, which is also to say the fact that we've put the wrong person in prison, yes, that's a tragedy for that wrong person for Peter, but it's also a tragedy for society because the real killer has not been brought to justice. Not only has the not killer been brought to justice, but here's what the statistics show. In the Innocence Project cases where DNA excludes the wrongfully convicted, and sometimes that DNA hits on a perpetrator. Many of those cases, that perpetrator went on to commit
卡森花费大量时间试图将身陷囹圄的人们救出来，但看待你所做的事情还有另一个角度，那就是，我们把错误的人送进监狱，这固然是对那个错误的人——彼得而言的悲剧，但这也是社会的悲剧，因为真正的凶手还没有被绳之以法。不仅凶手没有被绳之以法，统计数据还表明了这一点。在无罪计划的案件中，DNA排除了被冤枉者，有时该DNA会指向真正的罪犯。在其中许多案件中，那个罪犯后来还去犯下了
one or more multiple violent offenses, including homicides and sexual assaults. When you get a confession from an innocent person and close that case, you're not doing a whole lot of good for public safety. When we come back, what happens in our minds when we are induced to make false confessions and the use of police interrogation tactics in workplaces and private organizations? You're listening to Hidden Brain.
一项或多项严重暴力犯罪，包括谋杀和性侵。当你从一个无辜的人那里获得虚假口供并结案时，你对公共安全并没有做出多大贡献。当我们回来时，我们将探讨当我们被诱导做出虚假口供时，我们的大脑会发生什么，以及在工作场所和私营组织中如何使用警察审讯战术？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. So many TV crime shows center on detectives who have an uncanny ability to spot the right suspect. But psychologists saw Cassin as found that the confidence police have in their hunches is mostly unfounded. He once ran an experiment where he asked prison inmates to confess to two crimes, one they had committed and one they had not committed. How good were lay people and police detectives in telling truth from fiction. Bottom line was the average accuracy rate was 54%. Truth and lie detection studies give us an average when you meta-adalize all of the studies.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。许多犯罪电视剧都聚焦于那些拥有洞察力、能一眼识别正确嫌疑人的侦探。但心理学家索尔·卡辛发现，警察对他们直觉的自信大多是毫无根据的。他曾做过一个实验，让监狱犯人承认两项罪行，一项是他们犯下的，另一项是他们没有犯下的。外行人和警察侦探在区分真话和谎言方面做得有多好？底线是，平均准确率为54%。真假检测研究在对所有研究进行元分析后，给我们提供了一个平均值。
They give us an average accuracy rate of 54% exactly what we found. In other words, we would do about as well in telling about truth from lies if we flipped a coin. But that's not all. In the study, police were actually worse than college students at detecting deception. We found that our student observers were more accurate than our police observers.
它们给出的平均准确率正好是54%，这与我们的发现完全一致。换句话说，我们在辨别真假方面，表现得跟抛硬币差不多。但不仅如此。在这项研究中，警察在识别欺骗方面的表现实际上比大学生还要糟糕。我们发现，我们的学生观察员比警察观察员更准确。
In part, because the police observers kept over-believing the false confessions, and we found that the police observers were a whole lot more confident than our student observers. They were not accurate and they were confident, not a good combination. Rumpfl conviction's archives are filled with those mistakes. We simply confirmed that now in the laboratory. Saul and other researchers have also examined a number of psychological factors that cause suspects to make false confessions.
部分原因在于，警察观察员始终过分相信虚假口供，而且我们发现，警察观察员比我们的学生观察员自信得多。他们既不准确又充满自信，这不是一个好的组合。冤案档案馆里充斥着这类错误。我们现在只是在实验室里证实了这一点。索尔和其他研究人员还探讨了导致嫌疑人做出虚假口供的许多心理因素。
Some people seem to be more suggestible. This line of research was developed by a former cop turned psychologist, Gisley Good Johnson. He was a police officer in Iceland. Eventually left the force and got a degree in clinical psychology. He had taken much to his dismay of false confession, in a case, and became interested in suggestibility effects.
有些人似乎更容易受暗示。这一研究领域是由前警察转行成为心理学家的吉斯利·古德约翰逊开创的。他曾是冰岛的一名警察。后来他离职并获得了临床心理学学位。他曾在一起案件中非常沮丧地遇到了虚假口供，并对暗示效应产生了兴趣。
Gisley Good Johnson came up with experiments that mimicked aspects of police interrogations. He'd give volunteers a story and then ask them to recall it. And then he would say, I'm going to ask you a series of questions, and he would ask questions many of which were leading and suggestive of information that was not in the story. And he measured how many of those questions to people then insert into their memory. When volunteers recalled something correctly, he would also sometimes tell them How many of those questions do people then insert into their memory?
吉斯利·古德约翰逊设计了一些模仿警察审讯环节的实验。他给志愿者讲述一个故事，然后让他们回忆。接着他说，我要问你一系列问题，他会提出许多具有诱导性的问题，并暗示一些故事中并不存在的信息。他衡量了人们随后会将多少此类问题植入自己的记忆中。当志愿者正确回忆起某些内容时，有时他也会告诉他们人们随后会将多少此类问题植入自己的记忆中？
When volunteers recalled something correctly, he would also sometimes tell them they were wrong. He would say, nope, that's not right, you got to do this again. Eventually, he became interested in both types of suggestibility. Can we cause people to change their memory by presenting misinformation embedded in questions. And then can we cause people to change their memory by giving them negative feedback? The answer to both questions was yes. The studies found that some people were more suggestible than others.
当志愿者正确回忆起某些内容时，有时他也会告诉他们他们错了。他会说，不对，这样不对，你得重来一遍。最终，他开始对这两种类型的暗示性产生兴趣。我们能否通过提出嵌入在问题中的错误信息来让人们改变记忆？然后，我们能否通过给予消极反馈来让人们改变记忆？这两个问题的答案都是肯定的。研究发现，某些人比其他人更容易受暗示。
Children, for example, were easier to manipulate than adults. When interrogators ask leading questions, they may unintentionally change the memories of suspects and eyewitnesses. When detectives reject what a suspect or eyewitness says, they may think they are merely testing the veracity of the statements, but they might also be causing some people to develop inaccurate memories. We think that asking questions is a neutral activity, but in fact, the questions you ask can shape the answers you get. Another factor in false confessions, Saul cites a study by the psychologist Leonard Bigman, who found that when a stranger wearing
例如，儿童比成年人更容易被操纵。当审讯人员提出诱导性问题时，他们可能会无意中改变嫌疑人和目击者的记忆。当侦探否定嫌疑人或目击者所说的话时，他们可能认为自己只是在检验陈述的真实性，但他们也可能导致某些人产生不准确的记忆。我们认为提问是一项中立的活动，但事实上，你所提的问题会塑造你得到的答案。关于虚假口供的另一个因素，索尔引用了心理学家伦纳德·比克曼的一项研究，该研究发现，当一个身穿
a uniform, barked instructions at people on the street, they immediately followed those instructions. And he found that people obeyed that order at high levels. This arbitrary order from a stranger when they were wearing a uniform at high levels. And it just goes to show something about blind obedience. One of the other ideas that you explore is that we are really dependent on social support. Can you talk about the idea that one of the ways in which many interrogations are constructed is to deprive us of these social supports and the social supports in fact are integral
制服的陌生人在街上对人们大声下达指令时，他们会立即遵从这些指令。他发现人们以很高的比例服从了这一命令。当陌生人穿着制服时，这种来自陌生人的专断命令得到了很高比例的服从。这恰恰说明了盲目服从的问题。你探讨的另一个观点是，我们真的很依赖社会支持。你能谈谈这样一种观点吗：许多审讯的构建方式之一就是剥夺我们的这种社会支持，而事实上，社会支持是
to our maintaining our ability to function psychologically. Yes, it is the opening predicate of a police interrogation is to isolate the subject. Bring them in and put them in a room alone in our station and no friends, no family members, no phones, preferably in a soundproof room where they can't hear voices and phones out there so that they're feeling isolated and alone. My God, social psychologists, health psychologists know that people need people and that that need to belong and that need to affiliate, especially is true under stress. is true under stress. And that when people have social support present, they're able to tolerate more pain. Physiologically, they show levels of relaxation
我们维持心理功能能力不可或缺的一部分。是的，警察审讯的开场前提就是将嫌疑人隔离。把他们带进来，独自关在我们局里的房间里，没有朋友，没有家人的陪伴，没有电话，最好是在一个听不到外面声音和电话的隔音房间里，让他们感到孤立无援。天哪，社会心理学家、健康心理学家都知道，人是需要同伴的，归属的需求和交往的需求，在压力下尤其强烈。在压力下尤其强烈。当人们身边的社会支持存在时，他们能够忍受更多的痛苦。在生理上，他们表现出放松的水平
while under stress. It's important for people to have that. And yet, when you look at what happens in the interrogation room, the first thing is you are isolated and you are away from the people you know. The other thing they don't get in an interrogation, police are characterizing the crime, they're characterizing the evidence.
在压力之下。人们拥有这一点很重要。然而，当你审视审讯室里发生的事情时，首要的事情就是你被隔离了，你被带离了你熟悉的人。他们在审讯中得不到的另一件事是，警察在对犯罪行为定性，他们还在对证据定性。
They may be lying about the evidence. If you're alone in the room, you have no external checks on that reality. You can't turn to someone else and say, is that true? Do you know if that's true? And so you're not getting additional information. So you're lacking both the support that comes with people and the additional information that comes with people. Could you talk a moment about the role that sleep plays in false confession saw? You cite some really amazing statistics on the likelihood of false confessions, the longer a suspect has kept awake.
他们可能在证据上说谎。如果你独自呆在房间里，你对这种现实就没有外部核实渠道。你无法转身对某人说，这是真的吗？你知道这是真的吗？因此你无法获得额外的信息。所以你既缺乏随人而来的支持，也缺乏随人而来的额外信息。索尔，你能谈谈睡眠在虚假口供中扮演的角色吗？你引用了一些非常惊人的统计数据，关于嫌疑人保持清醒时间越长，出现虚假口供的可能性就越大。
The average interrogation lasts about an hour or two. Pretty much captures 90 some percent of interrogations. When you look at the archives of wrongful convictions, where time records are kept, and I emphasize that because often time records are not kept, and I emphasize that because oftentimes records are not kept. The length of interrogation is six hours, eight hours, ten hours, twelve hours, an average of sixteen hours, sometimes up to twenty-four and more. False confessions happen over time. Partly, that is a function of sleep deprivation and deprivation of other needs states, but there are no time limits set on an interrogation in the United States. And what happens over time is a person becomes deprived of food, sleep, sometimes bathroom
平均审讯持续大约一两个小时。这差不多涵盖了百分之九十多的审讯。当你查看保留了时间记录的冤案档案馆时，我之所以强调这一点，是因为通常时间记录并未被保留，我之所以强调这一点，是因为通常记录并未被保留。审讯的时长是六小时、八小时、十小时、十二小时，平均十六小时，有时甚至长达二十四小时或更久。虚假口供是随着时间的推移而发生的。部分原因在于睡眠剥夺和其他需求状态的剥夺，但在美国，审讯并没有设定时间限制。随着时间的推移，发生的情况是，一个人被剥夺了食物、睡眠，有时还有上厕所的
breaks. Certainly, they are deprived of social support, as we talked about earlier, which is in some ways as fundamental a need as anything else. And so what you find is that one proxy for a false confession, if you showed me a confession that lasted, the interrogation lasted 60 hours, right away I'd say that person was at some level of risk for that alone. Saul has come up with a number of experiments to see if he can induce false confessions and volunteers using only the kind of tricks and mild pressure that will be approved by university ethics committees.
休息时间。当然，正如我们之前所讨论的，他们被剥夺了社会支持，在某些方面，这和任何其他需求一样是一项基本需求。因此你会发现，虚假口供的一个替代指标是，如果你向我展示一份持续了60小时的审讯记录，我马上就会说，仅凭这一点，这个人就处于某种程度的风险之中。索尔已经设计了许多实验，看看他是否能仅通过大学伦理委员会批准的那种小把戏和温和压力，来诱导志愿者做出虚假口供。
In one study, he asks subjects to come into his lab and complete a task on a computer. Then the experimenter turns and says, turns to the subject, before you start typing, I should warn you. There's a problem with the hardware in this computer. Whatever you do, don't hit the alt key. If you hit the alt key, we may lose all our data, the computer will crash. So whatever you do, don't hit the alt key. Subjects says, I get it.
在一项研究中，他要求受试者来到他的实验室，在电脑上完成一项任务。然后实验者转过身来说，转向受试者，在你开始打字之前，我应该警告你。这台电脑的硬件有问题。无论如何，千万不要按alt键。如果你按了alt键，我们可能会丢失所有数据，电脑会崩溃。所以无论如何，千万不要按alt键。受试者说，我明白了。
About a minute or two in, the experimenter erupts and says, oh my God, what just happened? Looks across the table at the subject and says, did you hit the alt key? The subject says, no, I never touched it. The experimenter insists on a confession. Here is where the experimental manipulation comes in. There is another person sitting in the room with a volunteer.
大约一两分钟后，实验者突然爆发并说道，天哪，刚刚发生了什么？看着桌子对面的受试者说，你按alt键了吗？受试者说，没有，我碰都没碰过。实验者坚称对方招供了。实验操纵就在这里发挥作用了。房间里还坐着另一个人，与志愿者在一起。
This person appears to be another volunteer, but is really at Confederate working for Saul. For some volunteers, selected at random, this person now pipes up and tells the volunteer, I saw you hit the alt key. So what happened was that in the presence of false evidence, when the Confederate said, I saw him or her hit that key, we got a substantial increase in the number of people who then falsely confessed and agreed to sign the paper to hitting the alt key.
这个人看起来像是另一个志愿者，但实际上是为索尔工作的同谋。对于随机挑选的一些志愿者，这个人现在插话并告诉志愿者，我看到你按alt键了。所以发生的事情是，在存在虚假证据的情况下，当同谋说“我看到他或她按那个键了”时，我们发现随后虚假招供并同意在按alt键的文件上签字的人数大幅增加。
Some sub-number of them also then internalize the belief. If this experiment showed how false evidence can produce false confessions, Saul is also studied the reverse. He is looked at how false confessions can taint the evidence. In one study, Saul had a volunteer sit in a room with another person. Again, the second person was a confeder Confederate, secretly working for Saul. The two people were divided by a screen. They could hear each other breathing and moving around. All of a sudden, the experimenter entered the room in a half and declared that money had been stolen from an adjacent room. She separated the two people and asked the volunteer in a
他们中的一部分人随后也将这种信念内化了。如果这个实验展示了虚假证据如何产生虚假口供，索尔也研究了相反的情况。他研究了虚假口供如何污染证据。在一项研究中，索尔让一名志愿者和一个陌生人坐在一间屋子里。同样，第二个人是同谋，暗中为索尔工作。两个人被一块屏风隔开。他们能听到彼此的呼吸和走动。突然，实验者气冲冲地走进房间，宣称隔壁房间的钱被偷了。她把两个人分开，并在一对一的对话中询问志愿者
one-on-one conversation if the other person had ever left the room. Was she here the whole time? 90-some percent of the time they said, yeah, she was here the whole time. I would have seen her go out, you know, we were chatting away. The experimenter accepted this and left. Then she came back a short while later and said the other person had confessed to leaving the room
另一个人的离开过房间吗？她一直都在这儿吗？百分之九十多的时间里他们都回答，对，她一直都在这儿。我本会看到她出去的，你知道的，我们一直在聊天。实验者接受了这个说法并离开了。过了一会儿，她又回来了，说另一个人已经承认自己离开了房间
and taking the money. The confessed to leaving the room and taking the money. The experimenter asked the volunteer again, Are you sure she was here the whole time? And the subject now drops from being absolutely certain that this other person never left the room, too, I'm not so sure anymore. Now, more than 50% of them cannot vouch for her presence in the room with them, even though she was there breathing at the other side of this wall. They could no longer vouch for her presence because they heard that she had confessed.
并拿走了钱。承认自己离开了房间并拿走了钱。实验者再次询问志愿者，你确定她一直都在这儿吗？此时，受试者从绝对确信另一个人从未离开过房间，转变为我不再那么确定了。现在，超过50%的人无法担保她一直和自己待在房间里，尽管当时她就坐在墙的另一边呼吸。他们不再能为她的在场作证，因为他们听说她已经招供了。
And they didn't even get to see or read a compelling confession. They were simply given a second-hand account of the fact that she confessed. And that's what we've seen in actual cases. Once a false confession is out of the bag, it corrupts everything around it. It corrupts eyewitnesses, it corrupts, alibis, it corrupts, informants. It corrupts, believe it or not, forensic examiners,
而且他们甚至没有看到或读到一份令人信服的口供。他们只是得到了她已经招供这一事实的二手描述。这就是我们在真实案件中所看到的。一旦虚假口供出炉，它就会腐蚀周围的一切。它会腐蚀目击者，腐蚀不在场证明，腐蚀线人。信不信由你，它甚至会腐蚀法医鉴定员，
forensic science examiners. When you look at wrongful convictions in the Innocence Project involving confessions, almost 80% of them contained one or more other errors in evidence, and almost invariably those other errors came after the confession. Disturbingly, Saul has found that private companies are taking a leaf out of the police interrogation
法医科学鉴定员。当你查看“无罪项目”中涉及口供的冤案时，其中几乎80%的案件都包含一个或多个其他证据错误，而且几乎无一例外，这些其他错误的出现都在口供之后。令人不安的是，索尔发现私营公司正在效仿警察审讯手册。
manual. Take the case of Joaquin Robles. He worked for AutoZone. He'd been there for a year. He was aspiring to become a manager. And one of the tasks he had was he would take money from the store. And when the bank truck came, he would deliver the money to the truck. And one day, $820 showed up missing.
以华金·罗布雷斯（Joaquin Robles）的案为例。他在AutoZone工作。他已经在那里工作了一年。他渴望成为一名经理。他的任务之一是拿走店里的钱。当运钞车来的时候，他要把钱交给运钞车。有一天，发现少了820美元。
And the AutoZone had a loss prevention manager. Loss prevention managers are folks in charge of a retail outfit, or, you know, whether it's Macy's or Walmart or AutoZone. And they're empowered to try and recover the loss from theft of money and merchandise. So in the middle of his work day, he was called in by the loss prevention manager and interrogated. So you know what, 820 dollars is missing? It looks like you did it. It looks like you took the money and Roblesight didn't do that and I wouldn't do it. The auto zone loss prevention manager interrogated Robeless for hours and then threatened to call the police.
AutoZone有一名防损经理。防损经理是负责零售店铺的人，无论是梅西百货、沃尔玛还是AutoZone。他们被授权试图追回因盗窃金钱和商品而造成的损失。因此，在工作日的中途，他被防损经理叫去进行了审讯。你知道吗，少了820美元？看起来是你干的。看起来是你拿了钱，而罗布雷斯坚称我没做过，我也不会这么做。AutoZone的防损经理对罗布雷斯进行了数小时的审讯，然后威胁要报警。
And Robeless looked at the choices and he said, well, I don't really want to involve police. What do I have to do? And he wrote a confession, dictated to him in which he said, I took the $820. We had family debts to clear. I'm sorry. And he signs his name. And then he signs a promissory note in which he's agreeing to have
罗布雷斯权衡了各种选择后说，好吧，我其实不想把警察牵扯进来。我该怎么做？于是他写了一份按对方口述写下的供词，上面写着我拿了820美元。我们要清理家庭债务。我很抱歉。然后他签下了自己的名字。接着他签署了一份本票，同意让
that money deducted from his paychecks to compensate auto zone. He signs it, the money is deducted, and he is promptly terminated. Couple of weeks later, turns out that the $820 was not lost, it was a clerical error, and no money was stolen. But it was too late, you'd already been terminated, his reputation had been tarnished. When Robless was asked, why did you agree to sign the confession and give the money? He said, quite simply, it was worth $820 to keep my job.
从他的工资中扣除这笔钱以赔偿AutoZone。他签了字，这笔钱被扣除了，他也随即被解雇了。几周后，事实证明这820美元并没有丢失，这是一起记账错误，根本没有人偷钱。但为时已晚，他已经被解雇，名誉也受到了玷污。当被问及“你为什么同意签署供词并交出钱”时，罗布雷斯回答说，很简单，花820美元保住工作是值得的。
He figured it was going to keep a job. And so he signed the confession. What would you recommend in terms of ways to limit those, both in the criminal justice system, as well as in corporations? It also seems impractical to basically suggest that police can never use pressure or a manager can never make an employee feel uncomfortable, if in fact something horrendous has happened. What are your solutions to the problems of false confession so?
他以为这样能保住工作。于是他签署了口供。在限制这些现象（无论是在刑事司法系统中还是在公司中）的方法方面，你有什么建议？如果确实发生了可怕的事情，暗示警察永远不能使用压力或经理永远不能让员工感到不舒服，这也显得不切实际。索尔，你对虚假口供问题有什么解决方案？
Well, for starters, those sessions should be fully recorded, so that you and I, a prosecutor and a judge and a jury, can watch it later and understand for ourselves how that came about. Two, it's not a question of the pressure that is felt. Some of the most benign interrogators, investigative interviewers in Europe, for example, they apply pressure to suspects. But here's the important part. They ask open-ended questions. They don't communicate information about the crime. You know, when I get a confession to look at, I'd like to know that all of the facts in that confession
嗯，首先，这些审讯过程应该被完整记录下来，以便你我、检察官、法官和陪审团以后可以观看，并亲自了解事情是如何发生的。第二，这并非所感受到的压力的问题。欧洲一些最温和的审讯人员、调查采访人员，例如，他们也会对嫌疑人施加压力。但重要的一点是：他们问的是开放式问题。他们不会透露有关犯罪的信息。你知道，当我拿到一份供词进行查看时，我希望知道那份供词中的所有事实
originated with the confessor. And then I can evaluate with those facts accurate, with those facts not accurate. These are evidence-based techniques. And that's the goal right now. I mean, I think what I'm hearing from you, Saul, is really the importance of having investigators in police in some ways think a little more like scientists, which is when you're a scientist and you have a hypothesis, yes, you want the hypothesis to be true. But there also, the scientific method teaches you how to be skeptical of your own hypothesis.
都源于供述者本人。然后我可以评估这些事实是否准确，这些事实是否不准确。这些是基于证据的技术。这就是现在的目标。我的意思是，索尔，我从你这里听到的是，让调查人员和警察在某种程度上更像科学家思考，这真的很重要。当你是一名科学家并且有一个假设时，是的，你希望这个假设是真的。但同时，科学方法教会你如何对自己的假设保持怀疑。
And in fact, it goes to some lengths to try and prove your own hypothesis wrong. And this is, of course, difficult and painful to do because we're often successful in proving our hypotheses wrong. But in some ways, I think that's what I'm hearing you saying, which is that if you start with a very strong hypothesis and you start with a belief in your own infallibility, it becomes very hard to exercise this skepticism to say, I could be wrong.
事实上，它会付出相当大的努力去试图证明你自己的假设是错误的。当然，这做起来既困难又痛苦，因为我们常常成功证明了我们自己的假设是错误的。但在某种程度上，我想这就是我听到你所表达的意思，也就是说，如果你从一个非常强的假设开始，并且从对自身绝对正确的信念开始，就很难再去行使这种怀疑精神，说一句：我可能会错。
I couldn't have put it better. You're absolutely right. Saul Casson is a psychologist at the John J College of Criminal Justice. He's the author of Doopt, why innocent people confess, and why we believe their confessions. So I'll thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Shaka, you are very, very welcome. It's a pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
我再赞同不过了。你绝对是对的。索尔·卡辛是约翰·杰伊刑事司法学院的心理学家。他是《有罪：无辜者为何招供，以及我们为何相信他们的供词》（Doopt, why innocent people confess, and why we believe their confessions）一书的作者。索尔，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。尚卡尔，不用客气。非常荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德维克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。
Our Ransang hero today is Harvard psychologist, Maserine Banaji. She introduced me to solve many years ago at a conference, and I became fascinated by his research. Thank you, Mas Mazarin, for pointing us in the direction of a great scholar. If you would like to help us build more stories like this, please act now. Visit support.hiddenbrain.org and show us you have our back. Again, that support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vidantam. See you soon.
我们今天的无名英雄是哈佛大学心理学家玛泽琳·班纳吉。多年前，她在一次会议上把我引荐给索尔，我便深深迷上了他的研究。谢谢你，玛泽琳，为我们指引了一位伟大的学者。如果你想帮助我们制作更多这样的故事，请立即行动。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org，向我们表明你支持我们。再次访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
此剧集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。